[Musique]
ce qui s'est passé dans cette chambre de motel euh euh
était une nuit de coupon et j'étais en
train de trampoliner votre femme contrôle lm22 copiez-vous
Emma Swan
est le seul établissement Supermax
existant où il n'y a pas d'
éruptions d'abus physiques ou sexuels ou d'émeute c'est
la population générale jolie
justice impressionnante il a une arme
à feu au cours des dernières heures il y a eu une
infraction massive sur Mac et celle-ci
c'est une prise de contrôle de ma fille je suis toujours en
poste
nous pouvons envoyer un homme avec un
ordre très spécifique
Oh pour des vacances de rêve je suis chargé  Je vais
dans l'espace je rentre dans la
taudis à sécurité maximale sauver les
filles du président pas que je
dépasse tous les psychopathes je viens de me réveiller
ok
ouais à la fac
tu t'as envoyé ton vieux est-ce que mon père a-t-
il le message pour moi oui  tu as entendu
opté hé tu as dit que tu étais sûr de t'inquiéter
c'est parfaitement sûr
oh tu n'as pas à faire ça le simple
merci monsieur celui d'
Emma est déstabilisé pensé
au tableau vraiment avant - en fait
il y a une pomme que je dois faire  Ne parlez pas aux
étrangers, tirez-leur dessus,
c'était l'homme mystérieux sur son nom, c'était de la baise
étrange, ouais